how's everybody doing it good
I don't know if I should have worn this
I'm the only person who can wear a tie
and look less professional I hope that
guy's DWI courtroom appearance goes well
ah I am recently single my girlfriend
left me to go work at Google in north
California so the worst part about this
breakup has been using other search
engines you think you're depressed try
asking Jeeves something okay hey Jeeves
how far can I get this gun into my mouth
went on my first date back in New York
City and wasn't really well was one of
those like magical New York nights I I
walked her back to her place I I leaned
in for the kiss she leaned in to
reciprocate right before our lips met I
swear to god a homeless guy a stupa way
yells don't give them I swear to God
best-case scenario that guides me from
the future kiss him the robots will rise
you know trying to lose a little weight
here's my big weight loss goal I just
want to be able to have a salad and have
nobody next to me go hey good for you
that's what I was and I eat for
different reasons and healthy people you
know healthy people were like well I'd
kill to help my cholesterol
I eat blueberries helpin antioxidants I
drink skim milk to help with calcium and
I'm like I eat buffalo wings so I don't
feel sad cheese fresh so don't feel
lonely and KFC Double Down so don't feel
anything that's a you just bought a car
here bought a Honda Civic which I
believe is Japanese for crushing it I
was walking back to my car instead of
getting into my car I got into the car
park directly next to mine and I
realized this because when I looked in
the backseat there was a high-school
couple smoking weed and they were
terrified it was like the beginning of
Harry and the Hendersons they looked at
me and I'm like I made an animal noise
not even a real person noise and they're
like who are you and I go it's not my
car which didn't make anyone feel better
that's up there with like how do I work
this knife and they're like what I'm
like it's not my car then the switch
flipping they're like oh he's more
afraid of us than we are of him and I'm
like thanks for understanding hashtag
blessed but I understand why they were
freaked out because I look like
something that magically appears to you
when you're high and you don't know
whether I'm gonna murder everybody or
grant everybody wishes you're not really
sure no matter how I died
people were just going to assume it's
suicide like I could be found with a
gunshot wound to the chest and my wallet
missing and the cops would go up to my
body and be like huh must have felt bad
about losing this wallet and killed
himself gonna die
have some fun with it spoiler alert
we're all gonna die you know lay right
before I die I'm gonna say something
random like whoever I'm with right
before I die I'm gonna turn to him and
I'm gonna go find the boy and then die
who's the boy leave you guys on this I
didn't always used to do stand-up I used
to fight crime I was a crime fighter
I checked ladies purses before they
answered an art museum and for a full
year I was put in front of this museum
checking purses then I don't know where
my boss throws me in the back he doesn't
give me an answer why until I find out I
swear to god this is completely true
that First Lady Michelle Obama was
coming to visit and they were nervous
that I personally was to make a bad
impression I swear to God
what do they think I was gonna do when I
saw Michelle Obama like Michelle Obama
Michelle Michelle Obama please sign my
Michelle Obama action figure it's
actually just storm from the x-men but I
threw a pantsuit on her
[Applause]
you